Film Courage: I believe you made your first
feature film in 2013?
Did you think upon making this that your life
was going to change?
Aaron Fradkin, Writer/Director/Youtuber: I
guess if I were to ever have a period of my
life where I did have a chip on my shoulder
it was in 2012 making that movie.
I didn't really know what was gonna happen
with it.
I was very much focused on just making a movie
that I wanted to make and had zero intention
of trying to make something marketable or
anything.
All I wanted out of it was sort of just to
open a door and have maybe an agent that can
help me make my next movie or garner the attention
of some investors that would finance the next
movie.
While making it was an absolute blast and
I definitely hope for the best I didn't if
you were to actually ask me truthfully if
I thought this was going to be my big break.
I'd probably say no I don't think so but I
just sort of wanted to prove to myself that
I could make a coherent story and I think
I successfully did that at least you know
when I was 20-23 years old or so.
Film Courage: Do you really think that's a
chip on your shoulder or more just creative
longing, just wanting to make something?
Aaron: It was probably more creative longing.
I mean it wasn't like in a cocky way.
I of course hoped that we would get in a Sundance
and make a million dollars and there was a
small part of my mind that thought that could
happen i could see that happening now i don't
really think in that way so so when I was
younger I definitely you know the whole Sundance
dream and selling your movie for millions
and millions of dollars was it was much more
of a possibility in my mind back then whereas
now it might happen but I don't even think
about that.
Now I focus so much more on the actual content
I'm trying to make and just making the best
possible movie I can.
Film Courage: Would you advise other first-time
filmmakers not just a short but a feature
that would be really more of a again cliche
term but a passion project rather than aiming
for this incredible distribution deal?
Aaron: That's a very difficult question to
answer and I know.
I'm sure a lot of people will watch this and
and I want to be careful with my word choice
because I don't want to like lead anyone down
the wrong path.
Obviously everyone's different and personally
I think it's important to think you know about
the business of it and also think creatively
just how everything else seems to be a balance
in life you also need the balance of business
and creative like you at least if you want
to make a living doing this and only this
personally I think that's really important.
There are plenty of people who I look up to
that not once have ever thought about the
business part of things in fact they despise
it and they've only focused on the creative
part of it and and that's worked out well
for them and then there's plenty of people
that only focus on the business and you watch
their movie and you can tell but the business
is really working out and the creativity part
of it kind of suffers.
For me I like to keep both in mind all the
time when I'm actually on set or when I'm
actually in front of my computer writing.
I first and foremost I do my best to compartmentalize
and I just focus on the story and what it
is that I'm actually writing about what it
is I want to say and then when we go through
the revision stage it's like all right well
this might be more relatable or we might be
able to actually call this a horror film if
we add a few more you know jump scares or
you know just sort of add to it fluff it up
to sort of take your original creative vision
and make it a little bit more marketable so
you can make money and do it again.
Film Courage: What mistakes did you make with
15 North that have always stuck with you that
then going forward with a new project you
always remember those mistakes and try to
correct anything whether it's in pre, production,
post?
Aaron: I think I spent too much on post-production.
I realized later on that I could actually
do a lot more myself at least in that small
of a budget I could do a lot more instead
of spending money and hiring you know someone
else to do certain things although then again
the entire landscape has changed and you're
able to do so much more from home now than
you were just seven years ago.
I'm trying to think of of the biggest mistake?
I would say the biggest mistake that I made
on my first movie was not spending enough
time on the script i definitely approached
the entire project with this attitude of I
just want to make a movie I want to make it
real I'm just going to keep the cameras rolling
and you know get natural performances it's
very sort of mumble core style and I think
that that is good but I didn't prepare enough.
I feel like I could have fleshed out the story
a lot more with you know just really focus
on a more traditional three-act structure
and focus on writing characters with more
depth and and that sort of thing if there
was one thing I could do over again that would
probably be it is just spend more time focusing
on the actual script.
Film Courage: Do you think that prompted your
Youtube channel because you give such helpful
tips with your channel do you think that prompted
you to want to start it or no?
Aaron: CertainlyI think the content I'm putting
out on on my Youtube channels is basically
just everything I wanted to see.
When I was a few years younger I wanted to
see people creating content from home by themselves
and I enjoy that I love seeing people and
what they're able to do without big studios
behind them.
Would I take a studio job?
Of course but I really get a kick out of this
just home brewed you know do-it-yourself kind
of approach.
Film Courage: I think your top video is about
using the drawing aspect in Adobe?
Aaron: Oh yeah, the scribble animation, that's
funny.
Film Courage: Did you know that would be so
popular?
Aaron: No not really.
I mean I know it's a popular effect but yeah
with that kind of thing you never really know
it's gonna be popular.
With our other channel Social House Films
that's a lot more cut and dry.
If you make a short horror film and it looks
pretty and the monster looks scary then it's
probably gonna do pretty well.
These tutorials it's hard to sort of be on
the pulse of what effect is going to be.
The most desirable now that now that TikTok
is a thing you know a lot of people are trying
to like create their own effects at home and
and so I never know what that next thing is
going to be.
Question for the Viewers: What was the biggest
mistake you made on your first movie?